elle passe un cap plusieurs associations
de protection de l'environnement
saisisse la justice elles sont neuf à
s'unir pour demander l'annulation de
plusieurs projets ports industriels
projets routiers dans les yvelines les
associations dit stop en fait tomber sur
un territoire où les projets sont
conduits sans vraiment prendre en compte
l'avis des citoyens et aujourd'hui on se
rend compte que ces projets ne
correspondent plus aux besoins du
territoire effectivement l'union fait la
force mais aussi la compétence c'est à
dire quoi on a des associations agréées
l'environnement on a des associations
qui se battent sur des points très
particulier jeudi 17 mars se tenait
l'audience concernant le port de
triel-sur-seine à la cour administrative
d'appel de versailles porté par aropa
portes de paris ce projet souhaite
assurer une desserte fluviale de la
boucle de chanteloup déjà ce qu'on
reproche en premier lieu à port de paris
soit le mans d'avoir essayé de mentir
aux habitants peu sur la réalité des
activités qu'elle être accueillis sur ce
port et les nuisances qui pouvait en
résulter de la bonne nouvelle c'est que
le rapporteur public conclu à
l'annulation de la déclaration d'intérêt
général et de l'arrêté préfectoral ce
qui veut dire que comme les juges du
premier degré bien on s'oriente
probablement aujourd'hui vers
l'annulation définitive de ce projet les
neuf associations requérantes sont
soutenus par le collectif alternative en
vallée de seine qui regroupe une
trentaine d'associations
elles ont aussi décidé de faire appel à
des avocats spécialistes des causes
environnementales c'est un combat si
vous voulez nécessaire contre la
bétonisation des rives de la seine s'ils
voulaient cirque on a l'impression qu'on
construit des ports des projets
industriels terre la seule réponse qui
est donné de l'autre côté c'est
construire construire construire
construire sans nécessairement répondre
à un besoin donc moi je trouve qu'il ya
un moment il faut se poser se dire voilà
quel est l'intérêt des populations de
l'environnement est ce qu'il est
nécessaire de construire encore un port
parmi les autres projets contestés la
construction d'un pont entre hr et
carrières sous poissy pourquoi mauvais
projet parce qu'il est effectivement
dans laxe de la francilienne qui va
amener toute une circulation dans la
boucle de chanteloup qui n'a qu'un seul
exutoire quel point triel qui est un
pont récent réalisé aussi par le
département comme quoi le département
une bien les ponts mais qui en fait ne
débouche que sur l'a13 pour le moment
les associations ont déposé plusieurs
requêtes en annulation contre les
projets du port d'achères et la
requalification de la rue départementale
190 entre carrières sous poissy et triel
sur seine d'autres projets pourraient
être attaquées dans les mois à venir